just
ice
welcome uh we have the pleasure of
having uh twin fam from Stanford who
just completed PhD is now clay fellow
um talk to us today about structures and
random graphs new connections thank you
um yeah and I first would like to thank
the organizers of the workshop as well
as the all of the organizers of the
program for putting up a wonderful
program
so today I I hope to take you on a
journey it will be centered around
random graphs but we will reach out
towards new interesting connections and
to begin the story let's start at the
very beginning with uh adish
foundational results in 1947. so it is
proof that the exist graph on N vertices
for which there is no large week or
independent sets where large humans of
size around two times log base 2 of n
and well this is a theorem that edge
proof as an application to run this
Theory and we saw a few in the statement
here there's no Randomness but this
foundational in the sense that it kind
of was one of the very first
applications of the very influential
probabilistic method and uh it still
gave us pretty much uh close to what is
the best known lower bound diagonal
Ramsey numbers that we know today but
I'll get to that in a little bit
um Edge proof is strikingly simple so he
just needs to consider the addition
random graph example GN one half or in
particular a uniformly random graph and
then he considered the first moment of
the number of Greeks compute that it is
small and then the conclusion just
follows
so after adish there's been lots of more
refinements and in particular we know
very precise understanding of the clicks
and independent sets but also other
structures inside random graph and in
particular I guess for many of us here
uh we are very much fascinated by
structures in random graphs
but our story today will not just focus
on cliques and independent sets we'll
we'll kind of check a broader View and
we'll just start with random graphs and
then explore all of the old and new arm
and legs that the random craft take us
to and surprisingly one of the main
connecting line for us will be just the
rather easy or trivial first moment
consideration or first moment
obstruction which is actually the
underlying force of many fundamental
developments in the area so in
particular Khan and kalai they make an
important conjecture that predicts that
essentially structures will start to
emerge as long as you don't have any
first moment obstruction and first
moment obstruction also manifests in a
variety of different forms so in
particular around 2010 Michelle
talagrand in a magically insightful
discussion kind of realize that first
movement obstruction also appear in
other beautiful questions in the study
of stochastic processes random
optimization High dimensional convex
geometry and he connected to the subject
of thresholder conjecture and there he
also kind of builds a bridge that later
becomes important on how we connect all
of these advances to the advances in
sunflowers or robust sunflowers as well
and um well
um earlier last year I I proved the kind
of like conjecture together with Jin
Young Park and in particular now we know
that for very general structures
essentially uh we only need to
understand kind of first moment
obstructions and kind of surprisingly we
don't even need to go to the higher
moments
um so now is that the end of the story
well because we well this is supposedly
what I have always called the trivial
first moment obstruction so perhaps we
should be able to understand it very
well well one of my goal in this talk is
to convince you that the answer is no
and by going further we can uncover many
interesting connections of random graphs
to other areas as well so this is kind
of the rough roadmap for this talk and
we will roughly proceed in two chapters
in the first chapter we'll kind of
revisit edit's old story so we'll
concern with the very simple structures
like clicks and independent sets but
instead of just looking at the addition
Ensemble we'll try to inject more
structure into our random graph example
in particular we will look at random
Kelly graphs and then we will see Mutual
connection of the study with additive
combinatorics and perhaps even more
surprisingly we will see kind of an
interesting back and forth Journey
between additive combinatorial insight
and kind of more purely combinatorial
classical random graph type of analysis
and then in the second chapter of our
journey we will well switch back to the
simple independent identically
distributed example so in particular
additionally random graph but perhaps
now we try to look at structures in a
much more General way and perhaps we
want to find much more complex
structures than clicks and independent
sets in this case I would just spend a
short time to explain to you its
connection to this beautiful picture of
telegram on processes and random
optimization problems and then I will um
and well as we mentioned before kind of
the study of General structure now
through the conjecture reduces to the
understanding of the first moment
absorptions and then I will try to argue
that actually studying the first
movement obstruction will will require
us to reach out to our toolbox of
structural results and uh and and it
actually allow us to make quite a few
interesting connections there and in
particular in the talk I will focus on
just one recent results where we in that
study we we find natural connections to
the lowest local Lemma and kind of
algorithmic or something perspective of
the watch local level so that's the
second part of the talk
um with that let me start with uh the
first chapter of our journey and this is
about clicks and independent sets but
not in addition or any random graph in
more complicated models of random graph
so just to set up the basic terminology
um let me Define some basic terms in
primary theory that we will use given a
graph on N vertices we will say that it
is C Ram V if it doesn't have any click
or independent set of size C Times log n
so in particular in this definition we
can rephrase the theorem of edit that we
proved earlier as saying that almost all
graphs on N vertices are in fact two
Ramsay
and well a very classical result will
tell us that there cannot be any graph
on N vertices which are one half Ram V
and uh very recently we see an extremely
exciting breakthrough that shows that
there is some tiny bit executive
constant Epsilon for which there is no
one half plus Epsilon Ramsay graph so
this theorem here corresponds to an
upper bound on the Ramsey number and the
theorem of edit would correspond to
lower boundary numbers and whereas that
has been through time interesting
developments culminating in this
exciting breakthrough on the upper bound
on Ramsay numbers on the lower bound
side essentially within almost 80 years
of time from Edge result we have only
been able to improve at each lower
biomotives constant factor of two so it
somehow is a a very interesting problem
here and even more tantalizing even
though edit has shown that almost all
graphs have the property of being two
Ramsay it's they are in Jacob's term
these are kind of a dark matter that we
just cannot put our hands on and it
remains an open problem to construct any
crmv graph in a somewhat more explicit
way than just drawing them from the
random ensemble
so this is kind of one of the first
motivation for us to try to look beyond
the addition random graph Ensemble and
perhaps we can kind of shed light shed
more light on the floor bound or the
study of graph without logical
independent sets by trying to establish
similar results but in structurally more
complex random graph in samples so to us
the example that we will consider will
be Kaylee graph and random Kelly graphs
so in particular the process now more
interesting symmetries coming from the
group structure and um that makes the
study of the click and independent sets
more complicated but perhaps you can
learn something interesting from
studying these kind of more complex
example of random graphs so first let me
Define a Kelly graph so to us when we
Define a Kelly graph we will always fix
a group G which is the finite group can
be either a billion or non-abelian and
the Kelly graph is defined with uh if we
specify a generating set s which we
assume to be a symmetric set so
symmetric just means that if an element
is in s then it's inverse responsible in
s then we defined the Kelly graph GS as
the graph on vertex set G and we connect
two group elements X Y if x times y
inverse is an element of s and the
Symmetry constraint on S just perfectly
makes this graph and directed
so now we can also Define a random Kelly
graph and in particular to specify the
scaly graph we only need to specify the
random distribution of the generating
set s and so given a density parameter P
we can Define the random calligraph GP
as the Kelly graph GS where this
generating set s is drawn from a random
distribution where in each equivalent
class G and G inverse it's included
independently with probability P so this
is an equivalent kind of G and G inverse
just to make sure that the generating
sets that we consider are always
symmetric
okay so as I mentioned before there are
motivations from Ramsey Theory to
consider Kelly graph but but random
Kelly graph have actually made a lot of
appearance throughout computer
theoretical Computer Sciences can be
notorious group Theory and so on and
there are connections to coding Theory
and and other application as well so
that's some motivation to study Kelly
graph and random Kelly graphs and in
particular because our focus is on
Ramsay Theory this is kind of one of the
central questions that we will ask what
is the size of the largest click or
independent set in a uniformly random
Kelly curve in particular our uniformly
random Kelly graph going to be Ramsay
and related to this question there's
also an old conjecture of alarm that
asserts that in any arbitrary finite
group we can find the existence of one
Kelly graph for which it is Ramsey which
is C Ramsay for some constant C
okay so let me now tell you something
that we previously know about the
distribution of clicks and independent
sets in random calligraphs so along
previously proved a bound that says that
the click the largest click in a
uniformly random graph in any arbitrary
group is at most log N squared so okay
and in specific groups so for example in
the very nice abelian Group which is a
secret group ZN Ben green first proof
that the click number is actually bigger
of login with high probability so in
particular it is Ramsay and then by
refining the technique further in its
joint work with Rob Morris he showed
that actually in a uniformly random
Kelly graph in a cyclic group The Click
and Independence number will
asymptotically match that of the
addition random drug
what about other groups so the pretty
much the only other group that we know
more precise asymptotics is the vector
space F2 to the D which is again another
very nice abelian group and in this case
Ben green showed that the click and
Independence number will be of order
login Times log login with high
probability so in particular it is not
going to be Ramsey where's the parameter
P where did I go
so when I okay so when I refer to now
uniformly random daily graph it is
always the case that P is equal to one
half
yeah so
yeah so right so I should specify that
this uniform means B is equal to one
half okay and and this result of Ben
Green in the case of the finite few
Vector space is later refined to a much
sharper concentration result by mirzovic
okay so this is what we know previously
and as you can see apart from this
generic results which is off from log n
by a quadratic Factor all of the artery
zones can kind of require us to work
with very nice abelian group where we
know a lot from additive terminal
authorities
okay so our first man we don't enjoyed
work with David Conan Jacob Fox and
Leonard premian is that you can actually
upper bound the click the largest click
or independent sets in a uniformly
random Kelly graph on an arbitrary Group
G by log n Times log n and we already
saw that in finite field Vector spaces
this bar would be tight so if you want a
group independent upper bound on the
click or Independence number then um
this is that is login time flow login
and we can recover that in an arbitrary
Group G
okay so briefly how we're going to do
this we will consider of course the
first moment and the point here is that
the first moment will will be intimate
so somehow the structure of the random
graphing sample that we're looking at so
the group structure from the group G
must manifest itself through the first
moment and um it turns out that this
first moment calculation will naturally
take us to some question of an additive
combinatorial flavor so in particular
counting question on sets with small
product sets so particular the key tool
towards this theorem is this result that
we have on how we can count subsets of
General groups that have small doubling
another product set so what is the
statement
um if we want to count the number of
sets a of size 0n and for which the
product set a times a inverse is small
by which is less than or equal to K
times n for some parameter k then that
is at most the quantity over here and
actually each one of the three terms
that appear in this bound appear for a
good reason well they are only required
there and we can see that we can also
see the effect of each of these terms uh
manifesting in the asymptotic click
number that we get in the end but I'll
get to that in a little bit so just to
set all of the notations clear the
product set a times a inverse is just
the collection of all elements of the
form a times B inverse where a b are
elements of the set a and why does the
product set and sets of small product
come up is it's uh because if you look
at a set a and you try to see when a is
a click in the random Kelly graph GS
then that will only happen if a times a
inverse is a subset of the random set s
and so in particular the probability of
this event will be closely related to to
the size of the product set a times a
inverse okay so this the statement here
has a very inherent additive
combinatorial nature which explains why
it has only been sharply analyzed in
nice Pavilion group before and in
particular there it is it leverages on
strong structural results in in
isabelian groups as well as even a
version of the regularity method
okay so it turns out as I will get to in
just a little bit that how we can get
these results for General groups is
actually by trying to forget the group
structure so we just isolate enough
combinatorial information from the group
that is already to explain for this
small click number or to explain for
discounting results and then we approach
the Kelly graph with a kind of a purely
combinatorial perspective but I'll say a
little bit more about that in just a
second
let me now turn to a launch conjecture
and we see just from our previous
results that perhaps there is a
significant challenge here
so to date one of the best way that we
can get our hands on a Ramsay graph is
just by consider a random graph or a
uniformly random graph but now we saw
that in many groups let's say Financial
Vector spaces a uniformly random Kelly
graph is not going to be a Ramsay graph
with blue probability so how can we
actually show the existence of a Ramsay
Kelly graph when that when a uniformly
render one doesn't work
okay but we can look a little bit more
closely here and we observe that well in
the case of finite field Vector spaces
the problematic sets that account for
this additional log login factor in the
click number is actually just subgroups
or subspaces in particular sets with
very small expansion
okay and we can actually see an even
more precise version of that in the
financial Vector space let's say F5 to
the D in this case we can prove that
well there will be large click of size
asymptotically larger than log n
appearing in the uniformly random Kelly
graph but furthermore we can even show
that most of the time these clicks will
actually be subspaces of that particular
size
okay so our idea to approach a launch
conjecture is to somehow we still have
to take something random because we
don't know how to construct currency
graph explicitly but we if but we can
tweak the random model just a little bit
and just enough to make sure that these
subspaces will not be an obstruction to
us and in particular I'll again say more
detail about about that later we can
prove that for almost all values of n
all a billion groups of that order will
admit a calligraph that is Ramsay and
well there's nothing mysterious here
about this almost on it turns out that
we just need n to kind of not be
dominated by factors of low
characteristic in particular character
characteristics two or three okay so
there's something interesting in low
characteristics that that I perhaps get
to closer to the end of the talk
okay so let me now tell you a little bit
more about the ideas behind our approach
and as I I alluded to earlier there is
somehow kind of a very interesting back
and forth Mutual relationship between an
additive combinatorial Viewpoint and
kind of a purely combinatorial viewpoint
okay so in particular in the first
result that works for General group will
kind of approach the group structure
from a combinatorial perspective and our
analysis will be kind of a random
exploration that is reminiscent of
classical random graph analysis and for
a launch conjecture we do have to reach
our hands a lot more into insights in
additive combinatorics and so there it's
important that we realize the relation
between several several Notions of
additive properties well for example
lack of solutions to certain linear
equations or expansion in terms of
having large products set or Dimension
let's say you have a subset in a vector
space and um somehow the approach then
is to connect these Notions to the kind
of to combine this notion in additive
combinatorics also with our
combinatorial insights to to finish the
analysis okay so let me tell you a
little bit more detail about each of
these two parts
so first about the results are on the
click number in um General groups G
so let's first reconsider the role of
the group structure in this question
well if you have a group of order G you
can actually view Kaley graph in terms
of in in this uh in this particular
graph theoretic Viewpoint you can you
can say that what's given by the group
structure is just in some sense a
coloring of the edges of the complete
graph and if you color each X Y with the
color given by the equivalence class X Y
inverse y x inverse then what you have
given by the group is some coloring of
all of the edges of KN for which each
color glass is either one regular or two
regular but in particular a very low
degree
and achilles graph of course is then
just corresponding to an F Union of some
color classes and a random KD graph
would be the S Union of some random
color classes
and surprisingly it turns out that in
analyzing the click and Independence
number of random Kelly graph this
combinatorial constraint on the degree
of the color classes turns out to be
sufficient so this leaves are still
studying this slightly more General
random graph model let's take an
arbitrary Edge coloring C of the
complete graph
an entangled graph this is the analog of
the Kelly graph would be the edge Union
of some of the color classes and we can
also Define the random entangled graph
and this would be obtained by including
each color classes independently with
probability p
so
um we call this entangled graph just
because whenever an edge of a color
appears all of the outer edges of that
color also have to simultaneously appear
okay so now if we check into account
this combinatorial constraint that is
given to us in in the Kaylee setting
then we can impose that each color class
has about a degree
so in our work we prove that that
condition on the degree of the color
classes is in fact enough for both the
counting results and the click number
result to go through okay so you can
observe that this counting bound let's
think about the about it degree Delta as
it's constant this has exactly the same
form as what we claim in in the case of
the counting theorem for product sets
what do you mean about that but yes
how it comes into the play can you
extend this again yeah so so if we can
here just a question
yeah so the question is what is this one
or two regular color classes and how
does it come into play from our
consideration
okay so so let's okay let's let's look
at the candy graph so the vertex set
will be the elements of the group right
so now between two element X Y let's
label this h x y by the element X Y
inverse which is another element of the
group so when we consider kilograms what
happens is that we pick the generator s
to be in in the generating set or not
and if we pick s to be in a generating
set then all of the edges x y z t for
which uh let's say X Y inverse is equal
to S and DT inverse R is equal to S this
all appear in the clearly graph okay so
now if I just think that each of these s
is giving me an equivalence class of
edges in the complete graph then then
now we have a coloring of the edges of
the complete graph the colors are given
by the elements of the group G which we
think of as the elements in the
generating set and we see that the Kelly
graph would correspond to just picking
an edge Union of these color classes and
a random Kelly graph would correspond to
picking a random Edge Union of these
color classes and if we just like it is
a simple
um it's a simple statement to make that
if we look at the telegraph then each of
these color classes will have to look
like this so looks like they're matching
or it can be a it can be a cycle so it's
too regular so each color class is
either one regular or two regular
and right so the generalization that we
make is that we can just look at the
more General situation so just consider
an arbitrary Edge coloring we forget the
group structure but we keep if we keep
track of the constraint that the color
classes need to have about it degree
okay
so right and as I as I said
um the valid degree constraint on the
coloring is enough for us to obtain the
counting result and through the careful
Union bound we can obtain a bound on the
click number of this random entangled
graph okay so in particular this
actually resolves a question of
christopheres and markstrom so they can
they can they study what is called
random Latin Square graph these are
these are generalizations of random
Kelly graphs but but they are also
special cases of the random entangled
graph that we consider
are there any other questions
well this section started with the
question what does the root structure
have to do with it is the answer nothing
so
right that's the third thing that's an
interesting question so yeah so so far
up to this point we we were making a
statement that essentially if you just
care about the bigger the independence
number then somehow the group structure
is mostly lost except for the fact that
it manifests itself in just this about
the degree condition which is much
weaker than the group structure but that
is precisely how we can go beyond the
class of very simple a billion groups
and study General group but the group
structure will come back very soon
especially when we discuss a launch
conjecture so so stay tuned for just a
minute
okay so right
from some other structures
ah
yeah
I guess that we can of course if we we
are just allowed to look at an arbitrary
Asheville and we can cheat we can look
at something that maybe look and look
like a group for the most part and and
then there's some additional random
things that we add in to get somewhere
else so that doesn't that might not be a
very satisfactory answer but uh yeah so
somehow actually this lock log n Factor
it we believe what would come from
something very structured just like a
vector space which has an abundance of
subgroups
um but but yeah if you want to make an
example that is not exactly like a group
you can just take the coloring that have
like a vector space uh the coloring
coming from a vector space together with
some additional random stuff and that
wouldn't really change the distribution
of the click number so there would still
be a lock log Factor but it's not really
a group
the question is do you think that this
is
not in group school that's more steps if
you're making more convenience
characterize what kind of local
obstructions
yeah so so so so we do know that uh that
in the proof like like this block log
Factor would just appear like we do we
can pinpoint quite precisely where this
local Factor appears from from this
counting down and yeah it just happened
that this factor of n to the login
especially if we consider the case of
the final few Vector space it arises
exactly from consideration of subspaces
or subgroups of a certain size
um so yeah it's it's like the counting
results rather than a local obstruction
so it it kind of arises if we have many
many things in the graph or many things
in the group that that satisfy a certain
property yeah I don't know if that works
yeah okay so can you do better and
really non-abelian groups like the old
baby group
it's a good question so our guest okay
uh
well there are we'll see a little in a
little bit when we discuss the variant
on on a long conjecture that we have
also have some other uh random Kelly
Ensemble that is actually a little bit
better behaving with respect to the
click and Independence number and there
that that question is actually relevant
so here I would say I guess
um we expect that perhaps the the
behavior is better in non-abelian groups
especially very non-abelian group The
analysis we have so far doesn't really
look into the group structure and many
other parts of the analysis somehow
still plays nicer with a billion groups
than on a billion groups so we we happen
to get quicker results for
um quicker wanted quantitative results
not not this one but but the one that I
will tell you in just a minute for
non-abillion proofs but but that maybe
it's just a manifestation of the proof
technique that we are taking
um but yeah so we are not sure but
perhaps one can actually get something
quite interesting if you focus on some
specific non-abelian group where you you
still have like good understanding of
the rep presentation Theory and so on
the green morning
this problem about how many subsets are
there in Zima then small doubling and I
assume they're bound that they get for
this is a bit stronger than theorem one
because they have a strong result is it
easy to explain what about the cyclical
group is used there that allows them to
go below right so I will tell you again
it's just a minute when we get to a lost
injector when we care about sharper
independence of a sharper sharper
protected valve on a big number that
somehow and and they found there are
several there are several different
ranges that we have to take care of and
so first if we do carefully the analysis
coming from this counting ball to the
union Bell to the belt on the click
number then we will realize that somehow
we will get we'll be able to get sharper
dependence
um sharper balance on the click number
if we can make sure that this K is not
too small so if K is nominated by log n
somehow this login is responsible for
this additional log n Factor so it if we
can somehow look at situations where K
is at least not too small then it is
better for us so in particular if you
want to get a sharp bounce in the case
of Ben and Rob's paper then we want to
understand better what happens if k k is
small and there we actually have there
you know there you have not just maybe
this rough cutting bound but you have
much more precise structural reasons
particular daily drive there a
particular regularity type Lemma that
tells you very precisely the structure
of the set so so that's one thing the
other thing that that we will see is
that somehow the constant in front of
the The Click number if you want to get
a sharp result like Ben green and Rob
Morris then this constant in front of K
is the next factor that that will matter
to us and um
right again again uh I'll tell you you
will see it just a minute that this
constant in front of K is related to
certain additive combinatorial notion
like Dimension and so if you are in a
nice group and you have notion of
Dimension and you understand these
Notions really well then you can you can
sharpen this counting belt enough that
you get a sharper bound on a click
number okay that's actually part of what
I will discuss next
all right so well now
before we get to all of the shop results
when we have more information let's see
what to do in a generic setting where we
don't know so much about a group G so
first let me just quickly sketch to you
how to get a slightly weaker counting
down which is actually still enough to
recover about on the click number so
here you see that we have replaced K
Plus login as we claim and of course the
optimal result to K Times log n
okay so turns out that the main level
towards establishing this is to prove
that if you have a set of vertices that
determine few colors then you can find a
spanning tree
uh in this vertex subset that uses
relatively few colors particular K Times
log n
and you can prove this by consider kind
of a 3D process so in each step you
start with a single vertex and in this
step you pick a color that maximally
extends the size of the current
component that you have you can roughly
guarantee that the component Grows by a
factor of one over K every step so in
klock N many steps you will be able to
connect the entire set and this K login
and when I go through this now because
this scale again actually have a special
meaning in that this Lemma is actually
best possible so there you can construct
situations where you can cannot connect
the entire vertex set using less than K
Times log n many colors so if we want to
get the better amount of K Plus login we
have to consider something that is
different from this Lemma
and it turns out that what we need is
the following version so we give up on a
small fraction of the vertex set and we
can now actually prove that we can
connect most of the vertices in the set
then using much smaller number of colors
only K Plus login
okay so brief sketch of how we are going
to prove this we are going to
essentially analyze the connectivity of
certain random sub graph of this inside
this n vertex subset so we go back from
additive combinatorics to yet another
random graph problem and well in this
random exploration we will expose the
colors randomly and we try to analyze
the connected components that are formed
well when when the set of colors coming
out of the components is large so when
the components are at least sufficiently
large we can show that they will merge
very quickly in only logarithmically
many and above sets to create a giant
component as we need
so then our main task is actually just
to try to build reasonably large but not
very large component and in order to
prove that we consider this random
exploration procedure we keep track of
the colors the set of colors that go out
of each component and as the components
grow we show that the set of colors that
go out of it also grows but then we also
observe that the probability that the
component can grow actually increases
with the size of the component so it
will take a shorter and shorter amount
of time for the component to become
larger as the size is increasing so with
that Insight we can we can we can go
through the analysis and show that we
only need relatively few colors we go of
K to create many components that are at
least fairly large of size Omega K and
this is actually enough to then uh go
for another logarithmically many steps
and create a giant component
okay so this is a very brief overview of
our analysis and uh yeah as we saw there
somehow we there's a counting question
that is intimately about product sets
but but we go to this combinatorial
picture and somehow the group structure
on the additive information seem to have
disappeared so now we bring that back in
in our consideration of a launch
conjecture and as we saw the difficulty
in a launch conjecture is exactly in how
we can fix the uniformly random Kelly
graph in order to have something that
have a much smaller click or
Independence number which may seem a
little bit surprising at first sight
and so let me actually just focus on the
case of a finite view Vector space of
characteristic five will prove that
there is a Ramsay Kaylee graph on F5 to
the D and there's kind of an additional
free property that comes from our
construction that it is
self-complementary meaning that the
graph is isomorphic to its complement
but but let's not focus too much on that
that was just to address a question of
Nokia alone and alone or liske that
stemmed from um zero error information
theory in particular dual Source coding
but what I won't mention so much of that
connection
so
let's see how we can prove this
statement we know that we have to fix
the uniform distribution so this is our
fixed this is instead our model for the
random graph so well subject to the
Symmetry condition we know that for each
element X whenever we pick X in the
generating set we have to pick 4X and
similarly if we pick 2x then we have to
pick 3x so these elements have to come
in pair and before we were selecting
these pairs independently at random with
probability one-half so now what we do
is to make a very small tweak we will
make sure that we always select exactly
one of these two pairs for each non-zero
element X but we do it randomly over the
different non-zero elements X
okay so this will now give us a new
distribution over the generating set s
and it will have a few nice properties
so well it is obviously symmetric
because we force it to be and there's
this additional self-complementary
property but let's not focus too much on
that the most important property is that
the set s does not contain any pair of
elements that is one is twice the other
element
and in terms of the potential click in
terms of the graph this is manifested in
the following
so if we look at any subset a of the
group and it has some chance of becoming
a click in the Kelly graph given by
generating set s we can show that the
set a doesn't have solution to certain
linear equation it doesn't have solution
to the equation a minus b equals two c
minus d and we can translate that
condition as saying that if we add the
set a with a dilation of a by 2 then all
of the elements have to be distinct so
the sum is going to be very large
and then we can go through lunica Russia
inequalities over classical to an
additive combinatorics to show that
actually any potential click a would
need to have some expansion in that the
the difference that a minus a will have
to be fairly large compared to a
so this expansion together with our
previous counting is and is actually
enough for us to remove the local organ
factor from The Click number
okay so this is um the first part of the
story and as we already see here somehow
there's a lot more additive action that
is coming into the picture yes how big
is the constant uh you know it's crmd
for what C oh yeah so that's a
so right and if we use even more
additive information
[Music]
so it's not also so partially we are
using some information about a group but
more importantly it's how we are
defining the distribution of the random
generating set in this case it is not a
uniformly random set there is this
dependency that between X4 X and 2x3x
one of them always appear and one of
them always do not appear so that's
actually the key property in allowing us
to get a better balance for other Cooks
so for certain other groups so for
example we stated the results for like
uh General abelian group as long as it
doesn't have too low characteristics
um so so indeed uh this model you can
Define in other groups and analyze it in
other group as well but but so far the
analysis works best for a billion groups
so there's some other subtle reason why
it will not work as well in non-abiliate
groups but but yeah maybe I can discuss
that later
or turns exponent matter or any
expansion with one plus yeah so the
Fortress doesn't matter as I told you
earlier is the login that you are
fighting so as long as it's something
much larger than login your file
yeah so so
um yeah so in fact if you use even more
additive information you can show that
uh the candy craft that the random candy
crop that we constructed actually have
click an independence number
asymptotically matching the addition
random graph so I'll just mention very
quickly how this works so it turns it
turns out that as I mentioned earlier
this precise asymptotic is closely
related to the constant in front of K in
the counting result which in turn is
closely related to other additive
information of the set a like the
dimension of a and uh to get this
sharper bound what we we use is to
leverage on a previous result of kameven
zoha and lobet on fryman's conjecture in
the financial Vector space f t to the n
and that gave us some uh some good in
fact sharp bound on the dimension of a
and that actually allows the this
asymptotic to go through and uh somewhat
uh vague but also an ongoing effort is
that perhaps like if you want even
sharper asymptotic then it will require
even more precise understanding of the
additive structure and we believe that
it will also be helpful to correspond
that understanding of the structure to
the combinatorial analysis that we have
and if you make the full leverage of
everything perhaps that we can we can
get quite a few interesting uh
corollaries yeah and I want to mention
that yeah this is not a one-way
relationship right so this combinatorial
analysis can also inform us some better
additive information so perhaps we can
broader than the context of random
calligraph we can use this back and
forth relationship this Mutual
connection to derive interesting uh
interesting conclusions in additive
coming Athletics as well
okay so to recap on our first part we we
saw that uh in this when we inject some
group structure into the random graphing
sample then careful understanding of the
role of the structure on the first
moment is crucial in fact that it's most
of the work that we have just done so
far and we also saw in this case that
they somehow a very interesting Mutual
connection between this additive and
this uh Viewpoint and this random
exploration viewpoint
so the segment of the theorem well this
this analysis I just told you is
analysis of F5 to the D as I just
mentioned you can you can make a similar
construction and make it work over small
General a billion group as long as it's
not like F2 to the D or F3 to the D so
there's like a broad glass of a billion
groups for which we can generalize the
statement of a theorem too it's a
theorem that I stated earlier that we
can obtain a launch conjecture in in a
billion groups of order and for most
values of N and it's open whether the
same statement is true for
yeah and actually I'll get to that at
the end of The Talk
yes
okay so right so now let me proceed to
the second chapter of our journey and
now we switch back our perspective we go
back to the editing example so
everything is now independent and
identically distributed but in fact we
want to have a more General
understanding of the structures that we
want to find so perhaps we want to find
much more complex structures
so uh well yeah so towards this let me
again get back to this classical setup
so we have a finite set X we have a
random subset XP where each element is
sampled independently with probability p
and we also are given some collection of
desired structures H it's a bunch of
subset of X that we want XP to contain
okay so well yeah in this study we are
usually interested in the threshold so
that is where the structures in Edge
start to emerge inside XP it's the value
at which the probability that XP
contains something from H is equal to
one half
and um the current color conjecture says
that this threshold is closely predicted
by the expectation threshold I'll Define
right here but essentially you can just
intuitively think about the expectation
threshold as the trivial first moment
obstructions okay so it shows that it
the threshold is actually quite close to
the spot where we no longer have any
trivial first moment obstruction up to a
logarithmic Factor so just to set the
ground let me briefly Define the
expectation threshold it is the largest
value of P for which you can find some
other collection of says H Prime such
that first H Prime covers H in other
words H Prime 6 under H so you want
every set from H to contain a threat
from H Prime in other words you can
think that containing some sets from H
Prime is a necessary condition for
containing subset in H
and the second condition is that H Prime
have a small curve which means that this
sum here the sum over all of the set in
h Prime of P raised to the size of a set
is small and you can think about this
just as the naive Union bound or first
moment consideration with respect to H
Prime
so we say that H is p small if there
exists H Prime satisfying these two
properties you you think we think about
H Prime as a first moment obstruction to
containment of a set from H and so H is
p small if there is some first moment
obstruction
so now a restatement of the conjecture
is that as long as you are not P small
so as long as you do not have any first
moment of fraction then actually a
random set with density only slightly
larger than P will have to contain a set
from H with good probability
and if you don't want to remember this
slightly clumsy expectation threshold
the message here is that in existence of
the trivial first moment obstruction is
actually sufficient to guarantee the
emergence of structure
so as I briefly alluded to before and I
just want to spend a slide to tell you
how this is related to this beautiful
picture of telegram so it turns out that
this first moment obstruction is
actually a useful perspective to
characterize structure is essentially a
characterization of structure through
efficient covering and this Viewpoint of
efficient covering has actually appeared
in in previous work of telegram and
sarcastic processes so there are
interesting connections here to the
study of random processes and high
dimensional convex geometry and here I
State just I think one beautiful
instance of a conjecture electron
selector process conjecture which I
resolved with qinyan last year and this
is actually the precursor to our proof
of the kankali conjecture
okay so what is a statement here
the statement here is that well you have
a set X it's a bunch of elements thing I
don't think about them as items
you now have a bunch of valuations of
this item okay and these valuations are
linear in the sense that each of these
valuation fi assigns to each element of
value and the value of f i of a set s of
items is just the sum of the values of
all of the items inside of that s now
the statement you have to normalize to
make sure that the total valuation of
each function is at least one or equal
to one
and telegram conjectures that as long as
the support of this valuation is not too
concentrated in small spots so as long
as the support of the evaluation is not
Pismo then the supremum of the
valuations under a random specification
of the domain of items X will have to be
very large so you have to be an absolute
constant that is independent of the
sparsity p
okay so well I I want to just argue that
actually this is a very from different
perspective if it's a natural statement
so from the perspective of the study of
stochastic processes well this supremum
of linear evaluation is the suprema of a
stochastic process driven by Bernoulli
random variables and the statement here
is actually equivalent to some other
conclusion about the structure of tail
events of the this supreme of stochastic
processes
but the fact if we take a computer
science perspective then well this
supremum and nothing weird well they
they are actually just often called the
class of fractionally sub additive or
xos valuation and understanding the
behavior of the xos valuation under
random domains of sampling is something
of interest for many tasks in
theoretical computer science and closer
to the end of the talk I will mention
maybe also other combinatorial reasons
why we care about this type of quantity
okay so well an immediate relevant Point
here is that essentially the main idea
here uh the main idea of the proof of
the selective process conjecture in a
simpler setup so in the case where your
valuation is perhaps just putting
uniform weight on the elements of each
set in age that if that essentially is
the main step that gives the proof of
the kankalai conjecture and well if you
ask me why was the intuition for the
counter-like injector it's a general
statement that is true why is it true I
would argue that is somehow a statement
about the the structure of containment
or the containment function and you can
in fact think about the containment
function as some specific instance of
this type of fractionally subjective
function
okay so just a little bit on that let's
go back to our task we want to let's say
that we want to understand threshold and
threshold of certain specific structure
so how an imminent question here is how
we can bound expectation threshold and
the expectation threshold is given by
some large linear program with integral
constraints so perhaps a good thing to
do here is take the fractional
relaxation and telegram beta he took the
professional relaxation and do The
Duality and he shows that well you can
upper bound the expectation threshold by
something called the fractional
expectation threshold and essentially
your dual certificates will be
probability measures on the sets in age
that satisfy certain nice property that
we call B spread so a measure is p
spread if the measure of the sets H that
contains some specific set of elements
as the case roughly like P to the size
of f for for any f
so kind of like a global condition
and
um and well with this connection
um there's a weakening of the concali
conjecture made by telegram the
fractional calculate conjecture which is
actually intimately related to the
sunflower or robust sunflower
breakthrough and that says that we can
always up about the threshold up to a
small factor by the fractional
expectation threshold so essentially
this is along the line of the important
main Lemma in in the sunflower
breakthrough of Ry slope and this was
later refined in work of Franklin Canada
and in park okay and but also this is a
corollary of the cancellation conjecture
but okay again this is our goal this is
what we want to understand this means
that now we still have to try to put an
upper bound here or an up about here how
can we do that
um
okay so that's an imminent question and
previous to this we are restricted to
very simple and small sets of simple
structures that we can actually
construct these dual certificates or
estimate expectation threshold and in
all of these cases it works because it's
amenable to trivial enumerations
so there's a very small set of examples
that we actually know how to use this
result or the cancellation conjecture so
now this is kind of our position so
there's a gold mine here that we want to
get to this is the real goal and we've
built we've take lots of effort for us
to build this bridge to this other
Island that is the expectation threshold
but we are standing here on the shore
and we're not sure how to get to the
expectation special Island and I would
argue that now this is actually building
the bridges here and the expectation
threshold so building the bridge to the
first moment obstructions is actually
quite an interesting task that brings up
interesting connections okay so this is
the last part of the talk and there are
quite a few recent progresses on this
front on this front of understanding the
first moment obstruction that all brings
in very interesting structural results
that we previously know so I have some
Joy work with Ashwin sir metasoni and
Michael simpkin where we have to rely
crucially on regularity method embedding
techniques and the absorption method but
what I will tell you today is a recent
Joy work with Jane where we address the
same task but our bridge this time uses
insights from the algorithmic
perspective of the Lovato Lemma okay so
let me briefly talk about that so this
question is about finding thresholds to
certain design kind of object like Latin
square but in fact one version of it is
about Edge coloring of complete
bipartograph under random specification
of the list of edges oh sorry of the
list of colors
so let's look at the complete Bible
paragraph k n
it is obviously and colorable
for each Edge now of k n we are going we
are going to stop sample a random list
of p and many colors from this available
list of n colors and we ask is it still
true that we can have we can find a
proper Edge coloring of k n for which
each Edge received a color from the
corresponding subsembled list
equivalently you can phrase the question
this way
so an N by n Latin square is an N by an
array where you fill each entry with a
number between 1 and n and you make sure
that in each row and in each column each
number appears exactly once so it's kind
of a two-dimensional generalization of a
permutation
and now you do something like the piper
Digraph case for for each entry in the
array you subsample a random subset of
numbers so a random subset of n of size
P times n and you ask if there exist a
Latin Square for which the corresponding
entry comes from the subsampled list x i
j
okay so this being kind of a quite
natural natural you know design type of
object is kind of a natural
generalization of three uniform
hypergraph perfect matching and it's
related to other three uniform designs
like standard triple system and so on so
they have uh so previously uh the
question about thresholds of Latin
Square have been posed quite a few times
so starting with Johansson uh in his
work on xiaomi's problem so threshold
for existence of hyper perfect matching
but also reiterated by others through
time and the conjecture here is that as
long as p is at least some constant
times log n Over N then with high
probability we can find a Latin square
that is consistent with the subsampled
list or similarly if we sample roughly
more than login many colors for each
edge of the complete Bible Digraph then
you can find a proper list Edge coloring
of the bipat diagram and as I mentioned
there are other objects like standard
triple systems where we where it's kind
of closely related to this question on
Latin Square so there are also other
related conjectures
so in in my work with HS Jane and also
independently there's a work of Peter
kivash we prove that Johansson's
conjecture is true and also uh and also
that establish all of the related
conjectures for Cyanide triple systems
and Edge coloring of complete graphs and
so on and how we do this is by
establishing an optimally spread
probability distribution on Latin
squares which through the kind of like
injector would immediately imply the
threshold version that we have here and
I want to also mention that there were
previous important and interesting
progress on this problem by safanine
simkin and kangatron
okay so let me just briefly tell you the
Insight because that's my main message
so our main goal here is to construct a
measure of a Latin square that is spread
but our difficulty is that Latin Square
objects are highly rigid
so what is our Insight we will address
this construction task as like a
algorithmic task so we give an
algorithmic construction of threat
measures the algorithm has natural
Randomness built in to make sure that it
is automatically spread but of course
they have to fight with the fact that we
are trying to construct very rigid
things so random things don't tend to
work so well and so we have to employ
and combine tools from several different
things including iterative absorption
but more interestingly here the low
batch local Lemma
okay so this is kind of the summary of
the approach we want to start establish
the existence um okay so well so we kind
of break the task of constructing Latin
squares to multiple steps in this small
step you try to construct certain very
regular or rigid object the existence of
this object we leverage on the low-wash
local Lemma but now we take into account
one very good property of the local
Lemma that is somehow there's a local
uniformity property of the low-wash Loco
Lemma distribution that directly
corresponds to the spread property that
we want okay so don't look at this this
is the local uniformity property you
don't need to read at all the main point
is that if you look at the distribution
of solutions to the low box Loco Lemma
then it is very close to the product
distribution at least at the local level
okay and somehow that is perfectly
compatible with what we want for spread
and this is actually a key property that
were previously employed in works on
algorithmic glaucolemma and more
recently sampling algorithms for the
local Emma
okay let me skip the more details here
but uh I think the interesting Direction
here is to actually build uh even more
General more robust bridges that allow
us to obtain robust or threshold
versions of other interesting properties
that are given by constraint
satisfaction problems and there are
certainly many properties like this
okay so this is kind of the journey that
we have gone through uh in this one hour
talk and um yeah and and I guess like
here structural results came up and they
are very crucial and I think it's of
it's it's quite an interesting task to
build general Bridges between previous
structural results that we know in
combinatorics regularity method
theoretical computer science and these
kind of more robust random threshold
versions let me just quickly end with a
few uh connections a few invitations to
make more even more connections and for
the first one I want to kind of revisit
this picture of telegram and I want to
convince you that there is something
very interesting looking here so first I
want to to say that well random linear
programs are not a foreign object to us
so it's coming notorious we we are
interested in things like Max Cut Max
bisection these are random linear
programs and in fact like analyzing the
expected value of these random linear
programs under additional random graph
GNP which is exactly the object that
kind of appear in tala can texture is a
task of interest and it brings in
interesting connections to spin classes
so here this is an asymptotic what
involves a constant very easy constant
which is the Cloud State of the
sharington Patrick model so there are
very interesting Internationals here
somehow other gaussian processes pop up
and and and there's a there's a home
picture there and then we saw cyber can
select a process conjecture exactly the
same kind of random linear program under
some slightly different assumption and
we get this kind of magical P
independent conclusion and and as I said
before this this up the function that
appear intelligence conjecture also
appear in other places in theoretical
computer science so like in contention
resolution on studying the correlation
Gap in routing schemes and where where
and they're even a constant matter so
perhaps even the constant intelligence
conjecture has some meaning so it's just
as a general question how well do we
understand this home picture how does
the transition from P dependence to P
Independence take place so if you have a
p-spread system and you look at and
you're sampling at a much sparsal rate
what can we understand about the random
linear functions
okay and then there are other
connections uh some questions previously
alluded to a launch conjecture we
believe that at least in the abelian
case the case of finite view Vector
space is over F2 is actually one of the
very interesting cases and let me just I
just want to mention this because
actually there might be interesting
connections here so they're the in
additive combinatorics we see some other
manifestation of how low characteristics
can be problematic and and this question
actually also related to other results
in Ramsay theory that I will not get
into too much now
and the final question I want to post is
the study of sparse random Kelly graphs
and here we understand much much less
the alarm has a conjecture that they
should be have like a random regular
graph at least up to logarithmic Factor
but we are still very far from this we
are off by a quadratic factor and this
may again bring in interesting
connections to spectrograph Theory
Supreme of random processes and so on so
so I'll end here thank you
[Applause]
specific group structure because before
you show the test
structure of the group you can tell more
so I didn't understand how how what you
said in the end is related
so wait can you repeat the question
again yes yes
okay so the question is well I I stated
for some reason that we get for General
group that's somehow I said that in the
analysis you forget about the group
structure you're keeping you keep track
of some much more basic combinatorial
information and then I say that well but
then if you want more interesting
results sharper results you have to take
into account a group structure and use
more of the group structure so so what
is applied here is that the right the
right question yes and yeah so in the
first reason we prove this power block
and log log n which is Type in general
which we know that is type of financial
Vector spaces but well if you give me a
specific group The Click number may be
actually much smaller than login times
Block login so it's kind of a generic
noun but uh but but but but it's not
group dependent it's like the generic
and best known group independent bound
so and and then the Viewpoint there was
that if you just want this group
independent bound then somehow you don't
have to think so much about a group
structure but then we try to move
towards more precise understanding so
maybe we fix a group F5 to the N or we
fix some other distribution of the
random KD graph we want to under and we
want to say that we can do better than
the generic login Times log lock and
down so then I said that there we have
and we must use more of the group
structure and indeed we have a way to
use that group structure in in some
mutual you know yeah they're fine
because I saw that what you're going to
tell in the end but this part is also
related to doing better with respect to
specific groups or this what you said in
in the end was related to spreadness
does this also help you towards better
things for specific groups so so that's
a good question so in the end so in fact
you know like in some sense what we are
trying to understand in in groups is
also kind of a threshold type of
question so okay so the general redness
Theory it applies in general that that
there are General versions that generic
purpose things that we know and we can
use but in specific cases it's the
challenge right so in the whole first
part of the talk I wanted to say that if
somehow you are restricted to some more
specific situation so just click in
kindergarten then the generic purpose
tool doesn't help us so much and we have
to understand the specific situation
much much better and so that's kind of
the the message of of of the first part
so yeah the second part is more like a
broader view of you know trying to to do
more General things but I wanted to say
that if you know depending on what you
are doing everything has kind of it's
interesting which
all right
now if you address this uh related to
the construction in F5 to the D uh it
and you mentioned that you already have
an analogous construction after today
and three study because
the way you construct the this expansion
and low characters that uses this trick
with Pune with multiplying with two and
modifier yeah so so in brief why the
construction work over F5 is that
there's a way for you to ban the all of
the subspaces from appearing in a very
easy way so you just say that effects
appears two Vector doesn't appear
therefore there's no Subspace so in fact
there's enough room to trigger the rule
out all of the substances which is the
problematic contribution over F2 there's
no way that we didn't find any way to do
that but in fact there's more
interesting obstruction here in that you
cannot just say that in F2 you can find
a coloring which band kind of all of the
almost monochromatic large subspaces so
there will be monochromatic subspaces no
matter which color you you have that's
kind of a result in Ramsay Theory and so
that's a death that may be much more
interesting obstruction looking there
thank you
foreign